[Music]
here he comes and all eyes are on him
billy it's the busiest time of the year
so if you need a break from all the
holiday action best fiends is the
perfect pick-me-up it's seriously your
new favorite game what you're telling me
best fiends is a match three style
puzzle and adventure game all rolled
into one and with more levels being
added all the time there's always
something new to play that's right john
i'm really enjoying this as you know i'm
not the greatest gamer in the world oh
william but this is kind of simple i
know what i'm doing you have these
little fiends that help you out and they
get bigger and better and stronger as
you go on and you get to new levels and
i don't want to brag tom but i just
opened up a whole new level last night
oh congrats it's fantastic and my fiends
are doing good
i like the sound of that billy i i have
yet to play it but you have told me how
much fun it is you should it might be
the next game that i really get into and
if you don't have wi-fi if you're off
doing something it doesn't matter you
can still play fantastic so download
best fiends today for free on the app
store or google play that's friends
without the r best feat that was match
of the day one of the greatest
bbc one shows of all time i would say
and for anyone listening who was a fan
of uh football probably get quite
excited hearing that yeah thinking here
we go it's the match of the day it kind
of for so many people out there that
love football it kind of
is a tradition it's on at 10 30 at night
maybe you've just come back from the pub
early you've had your dinner the night's
getting long and then they put on the
week in football which is basically
little greatest is as a manchester
united fan right now it's not that much
fun watching match the day because we're
struggling but that song
as a kid you it reminds me of you know
oh dad can i stay out late and watch
much of the day yeah you can stay up
late what about the the song for the
cricket what would that be like dom
oh yes can you remember yeah i think i
can hold on eat a couple of nuts and
have a real something think about it
oh it's not quite done
it's like that did
well this is fascinating
anyway we're in a goody mood because
it's the first time we've been back in
the studio for
i think
four months
back and forward back and forwards but
i've been working away so we've been
struggling to get into the podcast
studio and
you've recently had a cold which has
kept you
well that has kept me in the house
because as we all know you know the
world over it's a strange time we have a
cold yeah
because um i've i've been tested a few
times for covid obviously yeah and uh
everything's negative but it's a worry
isn't it and you certainly can't
in this day and age go out
safe for instance into the supermarket
and sneeze no no no people will look at
you ass
looked at as the pariah am i using that
word where i am always struggle with
i always get mixed up one's a scary fish
the other one's like someone who gets
pushed to the outsides of society for
sneezing
hairy fish
don't they yeah they don't hang out with
the other fish they're all like oh wait
way away with a sharp teeth as someone
who knows about animals very well
are piranhas that scary or is it all
from that 80s movie it's a little bit of
a
scare-mongering tactic that film because
piranhas
tiny little fish similar to a perch
right now oh i enjoy up here not that
big i would say smaller than a smaller
than a uh kind of side plate not a
dinner plate like your little side plate
then maybe you put your
bread on type thing smaller than that
like a small pancake or a tortilla that
would be the size of a piranha right
they hang out in large groups so all of
them together makes them much more scary
and what's
what's
famous about piranhas is how quickly
they will strip yeah a carcass of its
flesh but that carcass would need to be
probably in harm's way if you're
swimming in the ambulance and you're
totally fine yeah and you're in piranha
infested waters blah blah blah
you know if you stood still yeah and let
them have a go at your leg then yeah
you'd probably be in trouble but would a
piranha approach a fully fit human
swimming and there's more of them to
start to attack you i don't think has it
happened maybe but you know you'd have
to maybe be bleeding so they'd come over
but it's a tight i mean on its own a
piranha that big yeah yeah on its own if
he came over to and it started getting
aggressive i'm sure if he kicked it in
the face it wouldn't come back for more
because i remember
actually i remember a scene in that
movie that piranha movie where someone
was sitting on like a you know at the
dock of the bay yeah a little dock at
the bay doing nothing much and then just
watching the time and then you just
and he went oh and it was a skeleton
from there down
i mean would that wouldn't happen
wouldn't it no no it wouldn't happen but
they've taken like a dead goat or
whatever and put that in the water and
as soon as because it creates this
feeding frenzy as soon as the feeding
frenzy starts i would think within half
an hour or so that goat is a is a
skeleton you know because they do
they do oh i've got schmutz on my face
don't you worry
to try this that's it i taught a lot of
people at work that word detritus that's
a good word good right little stuff in
it bits yeah
yeah i was mentioning it one day
because obviously you can't see your
face
um without a mirror
a strange thing to say
but i was at work and i was like i think
i've got
stuff on my face yeah and the megabytes
came over and said what do you have i
said i don't know just like detritus
around hingeman psoriasis i went no i'm
not
detritus dermatitis dermatitis and then
i had to explain what i thought detritus
was and then from then on any
opportunity for us to try and say the
word detritus during the day got like a
little ding ding ding you've said it so
good times on set you know i mean yeah
well wait i was going to finish
something about piranhas then
you put another one there was a goat
then
the go would you if you and i were on a
or inner canoe on the amazon yeah
and i said someone has to swim to the
other side there to you know
grab the grab the rope to dock the bow
yeah but just be careful billy because
there are piranhas around would you be
like well i'm not jumping in the water
if there's piranha or would you still do
it
i would probably still do it good for
you but i i wouldn't i don't know if i'd
enjoy it
because it wouldn't just be the piranhas
it would be everything yeah i've swam in
the amazon and it is unnerving because
it's the color of chocolate milk and you
just think
i don't know what's down there i'm more
scared of the candy room you know the
candy room or is that the one that goes
up your urine yeah you up your
urethra no but i thought well you were
peeing yeah it does actually go up your
urine yeah i dream i thought you were
mistaking the word urethra for your
right urine urethra urethra franklin
who's one of the great
singers one of the really great singers
so yeah if you
are urinating
or i guess it's gonna sound a little bit
disgusting but most
animals will have a certain amount of
urination
uh hinting going on in those areas
whether you're urinating or not you know
what i mean
like that that fish the candy root
doesn't need you to be peeing no it
knows where you're peeing oh it knows
does it know yeah because it follows the
scent and it has barbs on either side of
its of its face and it swims if it's a
male right up
the penis yeah and then
like wolverine uh-huh opens up its
little barbs and now you can't get out
and i think you have to have a
penisectomy what would you call
lopping a knob off no they don't take it
right off it's called a bobbitt i don't
think they take it off
well what do what's the fish called
candy room i think they just go up and
get the kandaru
really he'd make a real mess of you
the insane penis no
you'd be peeing like a broken sprinkler
for the rest of your life for what
reason
what reason does a kandaru go up huh
it's a good question and i should know
that because i do like animals and i
caught a candy roo in the amazon i call
it what was he up to
i caught three or four of them did you
just yeah we we were we were fishing and
we put like little bits of meat off the
boat and these kandaru came up and has a
so it creates this like mucousy slime
and as you pick it up yeah it creates
this mucousy like slimy ectoplasm stuff
but it also it was trying to like ball
into my hand it was very scary oh let's
drop it so i don't know i think it must
it either does one of two things yeah
eats
yeah the penis yeah but i don't think it
does eat the peas no
i think wait no yeah i think it later
but it's a male you said
i didn't say it was a mess and it goes
up the mail oh the female it's not just
male or female it will also well it will
head into a twinkle cave if it gets an
opportunity so if anyone knows why the
kangaroo we can't have the kangaroo
swims up your penis and lays its eggs
was it called the super candy roo candy
roo if anyone knows why a candy roo
would like to go up your pee pee please
write
a twinkle cave at um the friendship
onion at castmedia.com yes please do
she's talking about people writing to us
should we we have a look at some people
come on let's do it i might have a mouse
at one point but i've lost where's your
mouse it's gone now you've got is like
hammers and and and yeah i've brought
some tools yeah it's good in case one of
those missing behaves and then you can
like it
um
right hold on also we don't have johnny
clues with us this week
no johnny clues no johnny clues we're
premiering
a new uh friend producer with us this
time a new john smith who we're hoping
to find a nickname for live in this show
mackenzie smith has she got a mic can
mckenzie say hello or not no
no she can wave
can i just say mckenzie you're so much
prettier than john but john isn't
necessarily the prettiest man in the
world is he well he's quite handsome is
he and he looked i think he
he's got that kind of disheveled oh i
just woke up in a hedge yeah sort of
look yeah he's you know he's got that
wonderful kind of i might be hungover or
this just might be my look
yeah exactly i might have spent three
weeks like you know drinking my own
urine
but or i might just actually look like
this well we found out from mackenzie
that she doesn't like mac i had a friend
called mackenzie who did like matt she
doesn't like kenzie no she does like
kinsey no i don't think she does no
you're not listening
there's one thing she does like mac
oh is that right no she doesn't like
match she doesn't like kenzie but
there's one that she does like mckenz
she likes mckenz mcken's okay now last
name's smith of course smith we'll find
something mckenzie being scottish storm
oh yeah and meaning son of mac is son of
so it's mckenzie son of kenzie so
mckenzie would be son of kinsey yeah
yeah exactly
so but if you if it's um mcmiller
son of miller
maybe the miller of the town all right
mech
um what about was there ever a mcson
son of sun oh that's good doesn't yeah
anyway what we're doing voicemails first
all right first of all i think mckenzie
would like us to mention and i would
like to mention tom
quite soon although not this week not
just yet this week there will be
holiday merchandise to be had holiday
merch you say so outside of the normal
merch which is t-shirts and hoodies and
caps and stuff like that what do you
mean by holiday merch it will have a
holiday slant to it oh you're right it's
a little tickle just something there
no
i i've seen some of it and i like it
there's little snow things and all that
that make it look like christmassy and i
like snowed on the friendship on yeah
and i like that and also red and green
which is apparently uh holiday colors
which i didn't know in uh in the states
is that only in the united states i
don't know but like red for santa and
green for
christmas trees i don't know but red and
green they'll be red and green but i've
seen it i looked great christmas socks
socks
oh hoodies i love a nice hoodie so yeah
so at some point if you if you're
looking around the merch uh
place which is the
friendshiponionpodcast.com
if you look there in the next couple of
weeks or so you'll see some christmasy
stuff that maybe you could buy for your
favorite christmas eve friends there
will be socks
[Music]
now let's do a voicemail or two what
eddie come oh really all right
here we go this is going to be a
voicemail and you know who from tom
someone in perth
australia australia here you guys this
is simon here and i just wanted to start
off by saying you have touched me in my
brother's lives so much over the past 20
years me and my family have watched one
of the rings at least twice a year
and i use the term twice very loosely
so i just wanted to thank you guys so
much for that you guys are super amazing
but anyway my question is i know you
guys love league of legends so do i and
i just wanted to know do you guys play
the champions maokai or ivern at all
because i know you guys are such huge
fans of trees and ends and whatnot and
also did you ever get elijah to play a
game of league with you guys and if so
which champion did he play
well was that tame dom it's time for
flink up legends
[Applause]
league of legends well there's a lot to
be there's a lot to talk about oh
there's a lot to unpack dom right you go
you tell us your personal league of
legends though because you've really
you've almost turned pro at this point
i've yeah i've entered the world of
getting an s which has changed my whole
view believe when you told me that like
about a month ago you were like i've
never had an s and now it's like yes yes
dom i'd never had anything better than a
c
incredible i was playing the wrong
champions i think yeah you started out
playing kaiser who's quite difficult
quite difficult and then i went on to
nami and i was like
now tell us about nami she is a mermaid
she's a mermaid of sorts
and her ultimate
for anyone who doesn't know you get an
ultimate and that's the greatest thing
that your character can do
and what nami does is she sends out a
tidal wave
that all the bad guys all the people in
the other team all get shot up in the
air yeah and then the rest of your team
can go in and just destroy them yeah
yeah so i'm just i just sit back with
nami and i wait with that wave done and
i love it that's the best i've ever seen
you play you play you've jumped around
quite a bit the same as everyone else
we've all jumped around you played lulu
for a while
you played kaiser there's a couple other
characters that i'm forgetting i have
played a few but i i try to stick with
them because i i think that i like them
until i play another one and i think oh
that's much better which brings me on to
this week please when a friend of mine
says have you ever played heimerdinger
one of my favorites
a joyful character
it's the most fun i've ever had
i like them so much that i bought a skin
brilliant
i bought a skin where he's an alien and
his brain's on the outside oh that's the
mars attraction yeah like mars attacks
right brilliant and his little guns are
all like laser guns
and he is a fantastic character you like
space you like star trek and space and
sci-fi and stuff like that
jaime dinger was also played by our mate
nigel yeah i felt bad about that don't
feel bad i think she's we all need to
get over that because there's only about
150 champions and we'll all because
we've all tried lulu haven't we we've
played different
characters and stuff but
uh
nigel started
very early on playing heimerdinger and
one of the things that he that we always
used to joke about was this this thing
that he created called canon alley which
we talked about
so he basically heimerdinger can put
down tiny little cannons in like a
triangular formation if you want yeah
yeah whatever you want and as you run
through them if you mess about with
heimerdinger all of his cannons start
getting you oh he's brilliant he's in
this new show arcane
which is
on netflix
and follows the kind of
origin story of sorts
of a character that i love playing jinx
and a character that i don't play called
vi
okay they're kind of sisters and it
shows how they end up becoming almost
kind of rivals and
echo a character that you played quite a
bit yes high madinger's in there
heimerdinger imaging is amazing how is
it how was the show oh the show's great
it's great where do we see it the flicks
of net
netflix yeah nine episodes this they
staggered them out you can watch all of
them now but they they i think they
brought out four and then they brought
out another three and then they brought
the remaining
uh lot for four three are they making
more yeah they're doing the second
season wait wait don't rush me four plus
three seven yeah so they brought it out
and then they brought out the final two
there you go i got that again um
brilliant animation style very classy
you see the world of uh league of
legends which i think is called
runeterra and yeah and there is a
kind of new technology that has been
introduced the world that a lot of
people heimidinger especially is very
suspicious of he thinks it can do bad
things and then there's a kind of a de
facto group that's saying no no this is
great this is something that we should
do yeah and then it kind of
perverts
the society in a way not sexually no um
it's brilliant i absolutely loved it
they're making a second one
why why are we not doing voices on that
i think probably we
should for the second series but my
friend
carrie nigel's wife yeah ended up
watching arcane without knowing that it
had anything to do with league of
legends and was just like this is a
great show has anyone seen it and i was
like that's that's legally delicious
that's what your husband's playing every
night that's when he should be what
disappears into the cupboard yeah under
the stairs for like two hours to play
with us that's what he's doing so
it's great if you don't play league of
legends but it's really good if you do
play league of legends as well
i'm going to watch it the question from
our lovely friend there because yes we
digressed was has have either one of us
played maokai malkai or ivan and i
played ivern quite comically do you
remember well i never saw you please you
were in the game with us was i yeah
i was it was a walking tree yeah he is
an n it's the first time really that i
was a jungler and i was like i don't
want to kill characters oh yeah that
would be nice and with ivern he doesn't
kill jungle plants they protects them
right puts like a little orb of
protection over them um but you guys
were laughing at me because you never
saw me in the game at all did you like
dom where are you we could maybe use the
jungler's help and i'm like i'm in the
jungle and just walking around saying
hello to my little forest friends and
then maokai is the guy that
he throws out little
little kind of mates he's like almost
kind of tree-like and he's able to like
throw out little
kind of branches little twigs of his
that like run towards you
and i'm not i don't know who that is no
so we i played ivan in the answer to our
friends i've never played either of
those but i would like to try that i
like being in the jungle i like the
jungle too i just started playing
ziggs well for a while i've been playing
ziggs and doing all right as ziggs and
then back to playing jinx because of the
new jinx
arcane skin
that's really good and i've been playing
on my laptop
which is
probably about
15 centimeters the screen yeah but my
monitors like
i don't know
two feet yeah so when i started playing
on my monitor again after months of
playing on the laptop i was like oh it
just feels like i'm two levels ahead of
everyone because i can see stuff and i
got an s the first time i played i was
delighted with myself you should get um
you should get a projector
okay projector and just put it on the
whole wall well
i spoke to a friend i spoke to jake our
friend about that league of legends
right the reason why
people
the reason why you don't see people
playing league of legends on massive
screens yeah is the game is formatted to
to the maximum
of
a certain
monitor right so okay and any bigger
than that all you're going to do is
stretch oh you're straight you're making
it difficult so you want it to be
relatively small so very important uh
update uh that our friend wanted to know
there from australia
that was our australian friend wasn't it
i don't know
he sounded australian hold on oh
i don't have one of those okay i think i
left mine on the dining room table no
did you well i don't know who that was
because we don't have it on the screen
but
we we well anyway our friend who was
asking about league of legends yeah
thanks friend dead want to know about
elijah wood and has he put it
well bad news on that
have you spoke to elijah
well you and i have been speaking to
elijah quite a bit for a secret reason
yeah we'll keep that secret yeah
but
uh unfortunately both he and sean aston
have been not only reluctant to play but
i i've given up now well have you given
up i've not no i'm not giving up oh good
uh i did get a message i saw a message
on instagram or something where someone
said that they had been speaking to sean
astin at an event
and they asked them about league of
legends and this person said i won't
tell you what he said but i would
concentrate more on elijah okay so that
means sean aston's out
but i'm still not taking that as a note
right well i i think elijah's out as
well because elijah loves computer games
i know we know that about i know
he loves us i know
he loves hanging out and chatting to us
i think he'd be good at the game
and i mean i don't know
how many times have we directly asked
him now i'm gonna i'm gonna
conservatively say that i have directly
asked him to play the game
eight times
could we could we get it in
the scale of a fruit
chance of elijah elijah joining us well
we are doing
we are organizing things with him that
that might put us in a situation where
we could put him under an incredible
amount of physical pressure intense
emotional physical in the flesh i mean i
mean it's easy to say ah maybe via a
text but if we actually physically see
him
so you will you will you will do it you
play it put your hand on that mouse say
it
do it say it or i'll cut you or
something like i'll turn into an
i'll be elijah you'll be the gangster
listen to me son what is it we've been
wait a minute why is elijah from here
come here from london you know you're
from newfounds uh where's he from
idaho
now listen to me son why is it i've
asked you it's gotta be at least the
baker's dozen
times you will play league of legends
what you're f
taters taters wait a minute i went
london again yeah that's strange that
you can do that don't don't do my voice
a lot
i'll give you a chelsea smile son
if you don't play at the very least he
did it you did you've done the tutorial
he's done the tutorial
he told me he told me
so he's done all the hard work it's done
the graft and he won't jump in with his
mates i mean
i'll do you sunshine so next time we see
him i think you and i adopt maybe we
come across as like the cray twins or
something like we say yeah all right
yeah you play it right now you better
play it or else i'll do you son you do
you
so that's our league of legends update
yeah i think in terms of yeah sean astin
it's it's done and dusted hey dom yeah
liquid iv
you know that i love it or before i have
a workout when i get up in the morning
before i go to bed at night i've got
lots of times where i can find some time
for liquid iv
and now that the cooler weather's coming
in a lot of people make the mistake and
think they don't need to drink as much
but that's dehydration tom make sure
that you're drinking enough and liquid
iv helps you make sure that you're
getting your water intake you had told
me recently that you prefer liquid iv
than any other drink including water
what do you think of that that's an
incredible thing to say about this
product i love it too and it has some
fantastically yummy flavors i'll tell
you about a few of them
lemon lime strawberry watermelon my
favorite passion fruit guava pina colada
if you're feeling a little tropical or
immune support in tangerine they're all
super yummy they're great like you said
for after a workout or before a work
workout or let's say you've had a hard
day maybe you've done a long-haul flight
maybe you've done a little bit of extra
parting in the evening wake up in the
morning have a liquid iv ticket boo
lovely stuff and what makes it so
effective dom cellular transport
technology it's got the optimal ratio of
glucose sodium and potassium delivers
water and nutrients into your
bloodstream amazing so grab your
favorite liquid iv flavors nationwide at
walmart or you can get 25 off when you
go to
liquidive.com and use the code onion at
checkout that's 25
off everything you order when you get
better hydration today using promo code
onion at liquidive.com
dom
william we spend one third of our lives
in bed wow i probably do even more than
that yeah you're like a door mouse so
pure organic cotton sheets from ball and
branch make a really great gift for
people they make the highest quality
sheets by doing things the right way not
the easy way listen i like a good sleep
as much as the next person but i like to
sleep on very very comfy sheets i know
that and very very luxurious pillows
that's my thing you know me the gift
everyone wants is a better night's sleep
ball and branch never disappoint with
the highest quality sheets blankets
pillows and throws plus their holiday
holiday packaging makes your gift look
and feel that very much more special
that's true actually it comes in a
fantastic box and i really like these
sheets dom the more you wash them the
more comfortable they get they don't
like get all horrible like sub shapes
tilly
none of that no pilliness great great
quality sheets from bowling brands
buttery soft lightweight and made with
organic cotton weave that feels
incredible in all seasons it comes in a
wide range of colors and sizes from twin
all the way up to an incredibly massive
california king completely toxic free
and fair trade certified so treat
yourself and your loved ones to the new
standard embedding from ballen branch
their gifts come wrapped and ready in
their special holiday packaging order by
the 19th of december for guaranteed
delivery by christmas best deals of the
year going on now from the 6th of
december till the 8th of december with
promo code onion bowl and branch.com
that's b-o-l-l
and branch.com promo code onion
exclusions may apply
all right well let's see have we got
someone else let's do one more dom come
on it's nice to hear from people oh
hello this is nadia i'm from venezuela
but i actually live in chile right now i
wanted to mention something that i
noticed in the welcome to billy land
episode in the segment is it funky you
played a song by five alarm funk and i
couldn't stop thinking about the fact
that it reminded me of your song for the
quiz segment something like
i'm gonna watch your face
wow
i don't know if you can hear it but i
couldn't stop
thinking about that
so let me know what do you think and i
also had a question for both if you
could choose any banner artist in the
world to write
songs for each segment of your podcast
who would you choose and why
thank you
wow that was great
do we know what answers the questions
[Applause]
i guess we won't be able to get a
copyright of using that song but it does
fit perfectly doesn't it doesn't it fit
great she's brilliant from venezuela
living in chile can i just say i think
the most beautiful women i've ever seen
in my life were in venezuela now they
were scary women don't get me wrong
they're terrifying okay
we got off the uh
i was doing wild things we went to
venezuela looking for
the world's largest centipede as you do
yeah scalapendra gigantia and in the
airport yeah
we were all kind of
bored
and flawed
and wowed but yeah by just how beautiful
the women were we're like wow that's a
really beautiful woman now there's
another beautiful one there's another
bit they were everywhere and then we
went outside
to to our hotel everyone in the hotel
was was beautiful and then we did a a
couple of days on the streets of excuse
me i believe caracas which is where we
were which i think is the capital city
of venezuela might be getting that wrong
but i think so
some circus performers when you're in
traffic at a red light people come and
juggle and do some
unicycle stuff and we were filming all
that and again we were like wow every
single well not every single woman but
more women than you would think were
extremely beautiful so congratulations
to the country of venezuela here's
another fact you might not know about
caracas thompson
women outnumber men eight to one in
caracas
how do you know that it's in the movie
gregory's girl oh is that right yeah
now that might have dated now because
when was gregory's girl early 80s 1982
so
the stat might have changed but in 1982
it was probably
true there you go
um and the question from our lovely
friend yes if we could have anyone write
our jingles and stuff like that who
would we pick
so it was
off the top of my head
other than us because we'll write our
own jingles right great jingles but if
it wasn't us and it will be us
but if it wasn't us
i would choose
um
and i'm just blanking on a second name
right now
neil
from the divine comedy
yeah who are here
is writing the music for the new charlie
in the chocolate factory is that right
which i think will be brilliant neil
hannon neil shannon neil hannon from the
divine comedy yeah and you know what you
know i've been a fan of the divine
comedy for years yeah you played them a
lot in new zealand and it really reminds
me of new zealand i love them
and one of their albums passed me by for
some reason
called there goes the knighthood
and the last couple of weeks i've been
playing it and it is fantastic oh great
please listen to it
it's sort of
it sort of reminds me of
those great sort of british movies
you know carry on movies or even before
that
that's that sort of music
it's brilliant it's it's life-affirming
it's joyful lovely it's amazing please
listen to it the divine comedy and
there goes the knighthood oh definitely
let's do it because i'm on a little bit
of a scottish music tear right now
because i've been listening to the bmx
bandits quite a bit and the other day i
was telling you that i was listening to
frightened rabbit ah brilliant brilliant
yeah and you told me very sadly that the
the lead singer died last year uh
probably
probably two or even three years ago now
oh that's so sad lovely bandages
wonderful stuff yeah uh i would have
mr tim minchin oh nate
stand up comedian uh fantastic piano
player and i think did he write the
music for matilda the you are right
and it's brilliant one of the best
musicals i've seen in the last 10 years
and he wrote all the music for it and it
is wonderful that's a good picture he's
jolly and joyful and and full of whimsy
and he'd be great for the show yeah all
right what a great question yeah good
good questions is that it so we do these
now these are questions uh these are
emails oh
emails us this comes from our friend in
perth australia aaron
from perth in australia says hey dumb
and billy or billy and dumb she says
love the show thanks i was sent an
exception from my year 12 book from 19
years ago which i thought you'd get a
kick out of what's an exception i don't
know my question to you is
who would you like to be stuck in an
elevator with and in year 12 oh here we
go in year 12 2002 my pick was billy
boyd
thanks for keeping me entertained on my
drive to and from work from lovely aaron
in perth australia which is one of the
hottest places in the world right is
that yeah perth very hot not the one in
scotland no it's freezing but i would
guess that the one in australia was
probably named after the city in
scotland there's a lot of people they
all went over there didn't they
um
who would you be stopping would you be
stuck in a lift with hey
that's interesting i know my answer
because it's always the same is it
who has it you'll like it go on
siddhartha
oh yeah the man who became the buddha
yeah i think for my money
not that i have a lot of it but for my
money he's he's the most fascinating
human being like a dinner guest choice
siddhartha if you could ask any person
one question siddhartha so obviously if
i'm in a lift with the man who became
the buddha
just to just to pick his brain for a
couple of hours you better make anything
he may not he just sat there wouldn't it
you'd be like so you know
what what's it all about what should
yeah
nothing you get nothing nothing we'll
just we're all gonna die eventually
and that was one of his major teachings
is you can't get away from suffering
right we will all eventually degrade and
die and you need to make your peace with
it okay
which is a tough one so long ago on the
left that isn't it yes actually
whose would yours be we should be sent
to cindy
you made me think i better get spiritual
but you don't have to know well how
about can i just could uh uh peter
sellers ah brilliant and just see
i mean he'd do i know or like be really
funny unless you got him in a modeling
mood because i think sometimes peter
saws could be quite modeling
did you see him on um get back oh
we've not even talked about get back but
he arrived and get back didn't he you
did with the beatles he was doing the
magic chris christian with uh ringo or
about to yeah he seemed to be a little
out of place dude he was annoyed he's
like
i think peter stella's
in that state was like i'm one of the
most famous people in the world yeah
suddenly i'm in a room with four people
who are dramatically more famous than me
what do i do here
how can i be funny i think he was
expecting probably to be
you know
welcomed in a little bit
what would you like to drink peter
would you like a snack tell us some
stories do some of your silly voices
yeah but instead that's what lenin was
doing weren't he he was just yeah
a complicated character peter sellers i
think all all people are complicated if
you look if you look at them deep enough
i don't know about that are you sure
all right read that one bill are you
ready this is jerry from portland which
is in maine dom show me your hand
where
if my hand yeah well the united states
of america yeah new york california yeah
mexico down here yeah where would you
find portland maine i'm going to say go
up
from your wedding finger but on your
index like as if you were to put your
wedding finger on your index finger
right are you just
yeah i think that's me right that's mean
up there yeah okay so portland
north south east or west and maine i'm
gonna say
the south so i think so you're saying
about that yeah no
i think i'm bang on actually i think
that's not i do you know what i've got
absolutely no idea where maynard's got a
friend who has a place in maine it's
supposed to be very quiet i've seen pets
very beautiful but i think you're right
i think it must be up around about here
now but
the only portland i know
oregon so there's there's more than one
portland yeah
which brings me to this morning before
we answer this
there's more than one i was just about
to see you please don't say my home
address but you sent me your home
address this morning didn't you yes but
i included the postcode including the
call here you're dead dumb
and you said what did you see in me i
said put in the zip code did you see can
you come and pick me up because i don't
have my
[Music]
i have recently bought a car which is in
the shop yeah and i said to bills this
morning if you're on your way to the
studio yeah and you're passing by my
house do you want to pick me up and you
said absolutely
and i knew it wasn't on my way but i did
i didn't care about that on your way
but i didn't bother me i just said to
myself of course i'll pick you up john
i'd love to have you in my car and then
i was in and i was brushing my teeth and
i thought i'll just get my sin as
address so it's right there and then i
just click it
phones are good for that now they are i
said john do us a favor send me your
address
both i did it
i pressed it
i got in the car
it said i know her
i'm on the best day
i'm 30 minutes from you mm-hmm so i
thought to myself this time of day an
extra 30 minutes of traffic i can see
that in los angeles
so off i went and i was on a phone call
and i was just on a phone call for sort
of 20 minutes and then i started i went
on the audible and i was just listening
to a book oh lovely audiobook and i was
driving i was driving
and i sent you the thing you can do this
on your phone now yeah send your eta to
whoever you want so i sent it to you
i thought i'm on my way dom will know
when i arrive at his house it will come
and off we'll go to do a podcast
i'm about 10 minutes from your house she
phoned me
bills what's your eta i said that
i said i've sent you dom yeah i've sent
you i said i don't know how to find that
in my phone i said in the maps
department you were like i'm not too
sure i'm not sure but i tell you what
i'm going to be there in a and just as i
was saying a 27 i said i'll be there in
seven minutes tom i was very excited
because i've not seen you for a little
bit it got to about four minutes too
and i thought i should be recognizing
dom's neighborhood yeah
flags out dumb left side
i called you up i said dumb
i think i've gone to the wrong
address oh you started which is which is
terrifying dumb i've got some terrible
news
and i was standing up i thought i'm
going to sit down did you sit down yes
i've just i've had i've had a scan it's
not good oh gosh what i thought you're
gonna say did you really yeah i've had
some terrible news i was like go on
and i said
i don't think i'm at your address
and uh and and you said where are you
and i said i have no idea
but you seemed slightly angry you said
but where are you
and i said i've absolutely no idea
i said let me put in your zip code yeah
postcode yeah and then i'll know where i
am right and when i put that in them
your thing popped up and i noticed where
i was and you know where i was dom
i was almost at disneyland disneyland
you should've just gone you just said
let's cancel the uh podcast for the day
i'm off to disneyland on my own and
neither of us live near there's nowhere
no no and you were you were barren
i was apoplectic is that the right word
you said you said i'll get an uber yeah
just get yourself to the studio i was
starving so i was hoping that you would
because we you had planned to get here a
little early yes right and i thought
maybe on the way to the podcast studio
we could drop off for 15 minutes maybe
pick up some ramen sometimes i always
love some ramen today i've not had it
but instead
i just i got i said to you i thought it
was very mature i said billy yeah you
get yourself to the studio don't worry
about it anything else
i'll get myself to the studio
we'll just consider it
something that's we'll put it behind us
we'll never talk about it again
and dom it was another hour drive for me
i thought you were going to show up
sweating but you actually showed up very
calm
because instead of a 30-minute drive to
get here it took me two hours
and i went via
disneyland well i because we've been
friends for a long time now you you do
two very distinctive tells
when you're under stress i do too
one
sometimes you perspire oh yeah i sweat
like a racehorse you weren't sweating
when you showed up
yeah
also sometimes you'll show stress levels
on your skin
what oh yeah right i'll get red skin or
sometimes get a little bit red yeah yeah
that's the same
yeah yeah i'll get like a little
blushy hey dom it's holiday season hey
if you don't know what to get someone as
a gift or a stalking stuffer well
today's sponsor manscaped has the tools
to guarantee
you win this year's stocking stuffer or
white elephant competition manscaped is
the leader in men's below the waist
grooming and they have served out more
than four million men worldwide and if
my math is correct that's 8 million
balls
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com with the code onion
manscape's best-selling product is the
performance package 4.0 which is at the
top of every man's wish list this year
so i hear tell him what's inside him
billy inside it you'll find a lawnmower
body trimmer that's the best trimmer on
the market for all your downstairs stuff
and the weed whacker which is good for
your ear and your nose
get the performance package now to
receive their two free gifts the
manscape boxer shorts and the shed
travel bag the dads can't stop talking
about it the teens secretly buy this and
the women will love you for it now these
are our picks for manscape surefire when
stocking stuffers number one the
manscape two in one shampoo and
conditioner just launched killed two
birds with one stone
number two the manscape cologne infused
body wash number three shears 2.0 luxury
four-piece nail kit number four crop
mops balls wipes for your stanky ball
and number five manscape signature
cologne
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com with code onion be the
ballsiest gift giver this year with
manscaped finding the time or motivation
to fit in a workout during the busy
holiday season can be tough but with
peloton you'll get a fitness experience
that's so entertaining and fun you'll
always be looking forward to your next
session with its authentic instructors
and unique immersive content the peloton
experience is unmatched yeah i've got
the bike plus dom and i think it's
fantastic i love the bike it feels great
it's good to be on there but their app
is fantastic as well you always find a
workout that you want no matter how long
15 minutes 30 minutes 45 minutes the
kind of music that you want they'll get
great little things like
if you hear a song and a workout that
you like you can press it it goes
straight to your apple music list it's
got great stuff done yeah i know since
you started using the peloton bike not
only have you been telling me how much
you've enjoyed it but you look fantastic
and it's good for my dodgy knee and your
bum which you're building up you try to
get one of them big jennifer lopez bombs
anyway pellets are makes fitness
entertaining and fun working out never
feels like a chore and there's always
something new to discover peloton
instructors curate playlists as you said
to motivate your every mood from hip-hop
to country to rock and pop and
everything in between yep get your
favorite classes wherever you go in the
holiday season
visit
onepeleton.com to learn more try peloton
classes free for the rest of the year
that's new members only visit
app to onepeloton.com more terms apply
peloton when your workout is a joy it's
a joy to work out
and then when you eat sugar your [__]
gets at you does yeah very very itchy if
i eat too much sugar and i'm at home and
there's no one around sometimes i'll try
and create a buffer zone
around the uh
the sugary bum hole how do you do that
just with a finger
yours
yeah usually mine
it depends if i'm feeling lucky if it's
a friday night maybe someone else's but
not me mine
sorry about that what i found uh
relieves that there's a lovely glass of
apple cider vinegar oh yeah that was
thing that would take the sugar down so
sugary body
make it sour yeah drink something sour
neutralize the anus
and then you can watch a movie without
going
i wish i hadn't had that last silver
patch kid yeah
anyway anyway digressed jerry from
portland maine not portland oregon
portland maine which we've decided is up
here yeah
jerry says hello billy and tom i love
the show and all the talk about music
you once debated the beatles versus the
rolling stones no contest
but i was also wondering your thoughts
and two other classic british rock
led zeppelin
and black sabbath
are you fans
where do you rate them on the brahms
versus prince scale
would love to hear your thoughts thank
you you didn't say thank you read it
again thanks
never miss quote someone
oh wait a minute
thanks
exclamation he's got an explanation mark
thanks thanks
what was that capitals i just did thanks
no that's a question mark yeah no that
would be thanks thanks yeah how would
you do a semicolon
where is there something calling no
imagine it was is that a colon where it
says british rock is that a colon that's
a cool one a semicolon is a little uh
dash and a dot
pomerania a dot and then a comma at the
bottom
why would you choose a semicolon instead
of a colon do you know if anyone would
know that please send your answers to
the friendship onion at cast media with
the key
dot com does mackenzie know
mackenzie's not gonna make
just wondering mackenzie find him mate
come on we need to hear you here we go
mackenzie
we're just wondering if mckenzie has
great understanding of what would that
be it's not volcanic i would say that as
just the english language and uh grammar
grammar
oh yeah here we go mackenzie when would
you use a full colon or a colon or a
semicolon
so i believe a colon is when you want to
list things and a semicolon
is when you're putting two different
sentences together
wow that might be a new nickname you
might have to call it mackenzie colon oh
so mackenzie colon said that you use a
colon when you're listing something such
as lead zeppelin and black sabbath so
it's used correctly there you have a
color and you use a semicolon when you
are comparing two things is that right
mckenzie i'm sorry
when you link two sentences together
could you give us a uh
uh what do you call that an example yes
an example of when you would use because
we've got an example of a colon led
zeppelin in black sabbath do we have an
example of a semicolon
um
i walked down the street today semicolon
i found a toad
okay so
i walked down the street today
semicolon i found a toad okay
those two things are kind of in some way
linked together
but not with a comma yeah not a comma
why not a comma because both sentences
can be independent clauses on their own
because both sentences can be a sentence
on their own i think we found a nickname
i think she's mackenzie colan right my
scented clown is a girl mackenzie
grammer mckenzie grammar we're getting
there mckenzie grammar's a nice name
actually yeah that is good actually is
it too close to kelsey grandma it's
probably his daughter's name mackenzie
grammer anyway the question
uh oh yeah where do you stand on led
zeppelin versus black sabbath
i think on black sabbath windpipe i'm
not the bet i'm not the biggest black
serbia is that aussies band
i mean ozzy osbourne's
amazing legend what a character
i probably like
i mean this is going to be terrible for
black sabbath i probably like
five or six black sabbath songs what
would you say is the big famous one
ah
war pigs
sing it
oh i wish i could remember that generals
that's a general charlotte now my side
oh yeah yeah okay i know it love the
machine cheese turning
i'll see here we go here we go
[Music]
it's an eight minute song wow
that says class this is class no
question i love this scenario guitarist
the guitarist great cro is that a flag
and that he was in an accident and and
he
lost a couple of fingers ah
and he tuned the guitar down so his
guitar is tuned differently because his
fingers couldn't hold the strings like
they used to that's what chris did and
that's the crazy sound
sabbath sound great drummer forget the
drummer's name but he's amazing
in fact sabbath one good man
no question they're good it just doesn't
we could probably tell enough about that
wait no no you couldn't get to this but
now what went through all these yeah
forward a little bit no no here we go
here we go dom
[Music]
come on ozzy
aussie come on i see i was here come on
aussies
[Applause]
machine keeps turning
[Music]
i think that's featured a lot in uh
hip-hop licks always grab that little
bit when people are wrapping
brilliant now the thing is i'm sweating
yeah are you nervous announcement i
don't know
it's not it's not tax season is it no
thank god uh the thing about these great
bands yeah
zeppelin and sabbath and the stones and
the beers and stuff even if you're not a
fan you can get embarrassed by someone
saying what you're not a fan of sabbath
what about war pigs and you go yeah
that's a gem and they go all right well
what about this one but didn't he also
sing
changes i'm going through changes that's
aussie right so he's done something i
mean i mean
sabbath we're brilliant but
if you put them against zeppelin
i mean
that's not really really a concept for
me it's the same kind of contest as as i
would
oh see there's a stairway
brilliant
it's the way to it's the same kind of
thing as
having the conversation about stones and
the beatles you can make great arguments
for the stones but really the beatles
just floor them and for me
zeppelin is the greatest heavy rock band
of all time i'm with you on that dom and
their look they're designed they're all
so skinny and androgynous and the
thin scarfs and the hair and oh the
whole look is and even though
sabbath's drummer was incredible
i mean jimmy is it jimmy page or robert
he's a guitarist robert plant's the
singer singer paige is the guitar
guitarist and then the drummer is john
bonham john bonham probably the greatest
drama that ever lived really what about
ah
keith
moon from the who no no no nowhere near
really bonham
i've met some great drummers and they
all put bottom up there what's the band
that had the drummer with no arms
no one arm
def leopard he lost it in a uh accident
sure it wasn't no arms no he'd won
crashed his car yeah an accident yeah
crashed his car lost his eyes his arm
thought that was gonna be the end of it
i think so because you're fifty percent
worse
five no
oh nice nice
but the bands stayed with them brilliant
didn't sammy davis jr lose his eye in a
car accident yeah the chrysler uh sign
had a
a thing and
and a steering wheel a little sort of
point
yeah and i think he lost his eye because
of that
i think from the story i heard he had a
lady or two with him friends just pals
and uh i had to do like an emergency
stop because there was an accident in
front of him type thing
and he went bang
and his he poked himself in the eye and
his eye came out
popped it actually right out yeah
can you imagine that strange feeling
of like feeling it and being like no
it's not in there anymore maybe it was
hanging off the side of his head and
what could he see out of it then
i mean i don't know if he got pulled
over by the cops
on the way to the hospital and they were
like
give us your license and registration
and he didn't want to turn his neck he
could just go
give me a minute officer
just going to get out of the glove box
hang on i'll keep my eye on you
anyway
terrible zeppelin or sabbath they're
brilliant but zeppelin i would say
zeppelin
you know there's there's
lead settling songs that i absolutely
love and there's probably five sabbath
songs
communication breakdown
it's always the same
having another breakdown
grab you inside
i mean that break i remember my brother
playing me in that when i was a kid
because my brother got into zeppelin
once he started playing the guitar
and he played me that little bit in
community communication breakdown and he
was like is this like
one of the greatest sounds you've ever
heard in music just amazing
amazing singer jimmy page is a guitarist
where robert plank goes draw you insane
that's just
what's your favorite and they re they
reformed
and played one gig didn't it on is that
right i did not know that they reformed
and they played one concert at the o2
arena in london
i was there were you really i was there
wow
it was amazing when and it was about
i would say about seven or eight years
ago you lucky beggar i know i was i was
sitting there
uh
no garlic was there
they were all there john i bet they were
and who's who
no it was a led zeppelin
and they were fantastic much much better
than i thought they were going to be wow
i thought it was going to be a sort of
nostalgic yeah yeah they rocked man they
sounded amazing imagine the amount of
guitars that weren't getting played that
night i know everybody was there
luminary
was wearing sunglasses yeah
um what's your favorite zeppelin song
that's a good question
they did some uh lord of the rings bass
songs
yeah the thing the um black riders does
that means
something of murder they talk about
mordor a lot a woman
women from mordor and they talk about
gollum and
i was in the land of mordor was that all
that they're rambling now rambling alone
and were they the band are they more
attributed
than any other band as saying we need
persian carpets
but they are they that banned they said
when we do a gig it's persian carpets
i don't know if they think that was
exactly more than anyone else i know
that they had they were the biggest band
in the world for a little bit and they
used to travel in
private jet the zeppelin jet and all
that great some great biographies about
them as well oh they were amazing a lot
of uh did they partying let's say oh
yeah we'll leave it at that all right
great question well that was fantastic
dom hey do you know what we haven't done
this week and i would love to do it
because i know you're hungry starving
i'm hank marvin literally
it's a phrase but hey dom
we'll get an exciting one this week
for billy and dom
eat the world let's do it
as a kid right he reminds me
here we are and we are eating the world
and just so you guys know so it doesn't
throw you off if you are watching billy
and i we have moved to a different
position to try something else out this
week we think maybe it would be more um
advantageous
to eat at an actual table rather than on
uh um
like animals or dogs we uh we have moved
to this table here so um you'll see mr
don monaghan here on my left hello and
what are you eating today dom yes today
william we are eating something which
i've never heard of before and i love it
when we try new things this is black
mint paste
from peru
and i believe is it called hukatai
is that the name of it
hukatai
which is
so do people like it with potatoes i
think so honestly i've never heard of
this in my life i'm very confused that
it's a black mint paste but they use it
for pasta
mint in pasta so it's made from black
mint
native plant related to the marigold
family
with long thin leaves that have jagged
edges
this herb is made into a paste with some
salt and citric acid as preservatives
and is usually bought in
i don't know jars close that i think the
kids are super strong i don't know who's
written this but at the end
at the end of that it says it came into
my life it's an accident
do you want to try and open that see if
he's stronger than me see if i open this
just really easily this is gonna this is
gonna annoy you and it doesn't really
matter here we go oh yeah
maybe hang on we'll bring in the strong
mag
mckenzie he's done it
i slackened it for you of course
now
i'm going to give it just a smell that
your old factory
good idea
oh it's strange slightly minty yeah
it took a lot to get any mint but i get
that it's a little bit fresh i mean it's
a strange strange look about it i wanted
to do that great physical comedy game
that peter sellers does in a shot in the
dark where he smells the moisturizer
from the rest of the scene he's just
like
yes i know that
we'll get rid of that oh
i've not tasted it really you smelt it
i'll put that there i'm going to do a
little bit more reading here okay
i'm going to get a potato in it
the sauce is prepared with hukatai which
is why it's called hookah
a leafy green herb native to the andes
mountains which is found growing wild in
many fields and small farms it is not
formally cultivated because it is
self-propagating
and used by the locals in their
condiments is similar to the i hope i
get this right
or epazote plant which is used in sopa
de paico or pico
soup so it's similar to pico
and uh it's a it's um
it's a mint yes it comes from the
marigold family and it's
self-propagating which means it you know
it it
seeds itself so the plant
will
create little seeds that will fall off
and then create more plants so it
doesn't need to be farmed because it
does its own thing i get the feeling
because i suppose there was a time when
there was no farms
well they didn't know
it was old plants are self-propagating
now they're not
sure actually
otherwise they wouldn't be here
yeah it's a good point actually thank
you do you get the feeling that this is
going to be revolting i don't know but
i'm going to have this whole potato with
all right let's give it a try i've i've
put a lot on eyes a lot are you not
putting a lot on it would it be fair to
say it looks like dog dirt it totally
looks like you know if my dog bobby
johnson has eaten too much protein yeah
and not enough carbs yeah that is
totally what his pool looks like yeah
and i would not put that in a potato no
it looks like the runs you ready here we
go
first impressions well i enjoy a boiled
potato drum as you know
so i have to get through
the potato taste yeah because i enjoy
about potato as i say
i was recently in ireland and uh
the cliche that they eat potatoes is
completely founded because every single
lunch time it was just thousands of
potatoes to eat did you never have rice
yeah we did have a little bit of rice
but generally potatoes there would be
like a mini revolt at work if there
wasn't the option of potatoes now what
do you think it's all right it's like um
it's definitely mint there's a lot of
mint
but there's something else well it hook
a tie
is it the hook a tie again you're
getting a hint of hook attack there's
something like um an earthiness like a
hue of huckabee you know like mint is
very sort of fresh and i would say in a
sort of
airy way
this feels very earthy
earthy i think that's a good description
i don't
i would say it's unpleasant
now the people who like mastication are
having a great time right now and the
people who don't because what was your
guts what i was doing there is i had no
potato with it because the potato was
making me
enjoy it too much so i'm taking it as it
is and then forcing it against the top
you've managed to stain your teeth quite
a lot with it
but i'm forcing it against the top of my
mouth if you will the roof do it again
together real taste and then it's
squirting
like
in between my
my back teeth and my gums i've tried it
on its own and it's not got any better
look
that's disgusting because then it's
right back
in my palette they're dumb which i i
guess is where my my taste buds are i
thought your taste buds are all over
your tongue are they well i thought so
wait hold on
you do your thing i'm going to read this
in peru and other latin american
countries now can i just say to any of
any of uh people any of the people
listening from peru
hello or ola oh well done peru is one of
my favorite countries in the world i've
been there probably
eight times and i just absolutely love
it i've never been done especially the
city of aquitos hello to everyone who
lives in aquitos if you're there uh
it says here in peru and other latin
american countries the hookah thai
leaves are crushed using a fulling mill
stone tool that serves as a traditional
blender this grinds the leaves more
coarsely than a modern blender might but
allows greater absorption of flavor the
sauce is easy to prepare oh goodness
typically takes 15 to 30 minutes to make
it's traditionally used in the
preparation of chicken parties
i love the idea of a chicken chicken
party now is that a party for chickens
or a party where you eat chickens
hopefully fortress four chickens or
barbecues but many households prepare it
on a regular basis
traditional ingredients
oil
queso fresco
fresh cheese right
jellies of a chili i'd love some
chillies have a look at that and tell me
for chili's in that would you
garlic cilantro otherwise known as um uh
hold on don't tell me no i won't
um cilantro come on hold on we went to a
wedding where they wouldn't allow
cilantro to remember the
groom yeah we we we were the witnesses
at our wedding and the groom
was violently oh that was just right
yeah
you still don't know no i do oh do you
want me to see the name yeah andrew jack
yeah and the name of cilantro oh right
um uh
cilantro because over over in america
they don't they call it cilantro but
they call the seed
as uh i always know when billy's gonna
get something when he's not gonna get it
and he's not gonna get it i'm not gonna
get it right hold on then because it's
not cardamon right now you're in the
right ballpark it's a see they call it a
seed here but we call
scallions which is a tiny little onion
it's a red is it does a scallion become
an onion no i don't think so i think
that's something scallion is always it's
almost like a dwarfed onion wow right so
i don't think it's ever going to become
a big one because you get like red
onions and pearl onions and they get
much bigger the scallions are always
small and so
every single one of these ingredients i
love oil great fresh cheese love chilies
love garlic love cilantro or coriander
love scallions love salt love i don't
love this okay dom i think it's all
right but i don't do you love it no
do you like it
i'm not sure yeah i don't know i don't i
i try it in pasta now i don't want to
try it in pasta would you heat it up for
pasta i don't think it goes well
necessarily i mean i could see it on a
bit of fish whose idea was this did
someone send it in i thought it came
from johnny clothes hey he's not around
today yeah who knows i don't think this
is something mckenzie would give us
if you if you look over at the window
then because she's actually laughing not
with us but actors like mckenzie's
grandma what's up mckenzie i think
mckenzie finds it disgusting and she
wants to see if we found it disgusting i
think she's tried it hasn't she and she
doesn't like it i like it it's all right
quite quite a dominant salt taste so we
give you some scores
uh first off i'm going to do you a quiz
go on
right
that's 45
uh servings okay 45 servings than that
right yeah so divide that by 45. easy
how many calories in a serving how many
calories in a 45 worths of that yeah
i don't think a lot because is there any
sugar
no
so it's all that um
two
but hang on really let's see
brilliant that's fantastic
you when the jar i'd like that actually
right right let's give it some score
right go on then flavor flavor another
go on its own for flavor flavor
terrible ten i mean dom i'm gonna have
to just give her a three
it's a very dominating kind of like you
said four four
earthly swampy almost marsh like yeah
but salt is well i like the salt i like
the salt i like the salt i like the
marsh is it like is it like seaweed
that's gone bad or something like that
yeah it's like unfortunately like an old
man you've got it like on the side i
mean it's earthy it's heavy though it
feels like you're eating the ground
you've given it a fall
i don't know if it needs to be kinda
because i'll i love peru i'll give it a
five five not bad and what about
aesthetics oh god i mean it looks like
dog dirt
so it's not the jars all right it shows
you the the leaf that it's made from
like that it's you know there's a lot of
leafy vegetable type herbie things in
there what do you think i don't i mean
look at that it just looks like poo
doesn't it don't it does a little bit
thanks
i'll be kind i'll give it a one that's
kind as kind
well i'm going to say because it's got
this sort of leafiness and that sort of
rough
as you said it is
you know the way that it's been blended
is coarse i quite like that so i'm going
to give it a
6.2
right now that's quite good
usefulness
usefulness well it says you put you
usually put it on chicken it says you
have it in pasta don't see how it works
in pasta i wouldn't put it in a barbecue
would you
pasta i don't even think a mint a minty
salty pasta i can't see how that would
be how would it um
i mean as a dip with like tortillas
would it work like that
i've got i've got some
tubs in the house on that just sit there
and then every couple of years they'll
get thrown in the bin you can have tips
that you don't like just just things
that i've bought
you know you thought oh i'll use that
yeah i sing that
who could i could do could well end up
like that yeah
sat in the very back of the fridge and
you think well it's not going to go bad
so i'll just keep it but then you think
well what would you ever use it for and
it's like 18 years later and you think
can i still use that you probably
couldn't
you shouldn't
well for the peruvian people it might be
much more useful but for me personally
from a useful point of view i'm gonna
say
i'll give it a four
i'm going to give it a 3.5 done it's not
done very well it's not who could thai
has not done well in the friendship
onion
that's it for billion dollar please send
in your suggestions and even though the
hookah thai
black mint pace didn't necessarily get
the best scores this is one of our
favorite ones to do something we've
never heard of before that's right it's
a bit peculiar we'll be brave we'll try
our best so send in your suggestions to
us
speak pipe forward slash
the friendship onion or you can send an
email to the friendship onion at
castmedia.com
guys that's it what that dumb i really
enjoyed it i enjoyed it
we're leaving you skinny
[Music]
we have to say bye don't we we do but we
talked about a lot today and i enjoyed
it you were absolutely wonderful company
i felt the same way if i was giving you
a score today it's a classic 10 out of
10. i can't wait for next week and next
week we have a fantastic guest i won't
tell you who is a guest oh yes brilliant
and just to remind you guys if you're
buying merchandise from us at the
friendshiponionpodcast.com we very much
appreciate it but if you want to buy
specific christmas gifts go have a look
because there's some festive wear there
and who knows in the next couple weeks
we might be wearing some of those
festive things too i want to pair those
socks i can't wait on friendship we
should make a scarf i enjoy your scarf
yeah let's do it all right you guys
we'll see you next week see you next
time
[Music]